el día de la pachamama el primero de
agosto es una ceremonia ancestral que
tiene sus orígenes y se sigue celebrando
por supuesto en las regiones andinas
también en argentina pero en este caso
estamos a 5 minutos de la ciudad de
buenos aires en las afueras en una zona
urbana y está comenzando en este espacio
distinto en este centro comunitario
quechua este día de la pachamama urbano
cada uno construye su espacio su pacha
su casa su lugar como lo siente el
corazón y si uno es uno uno está
conectado con la tierra con la sal para
mamá con la naturaleza eso fluye en el
lugar que está están en pleno centro con
el asfalto podemos ver los insectos las
aves que vuelan y los lugares donde la
pachamama se abre paso
[Música]
aparte que tiene este complejo ritual de
la pachamama llegó el momento de
entregar las ofrendas de darle de comer
pachamama se acercándonos más hacia el
momento del final de este ritual
haciendo esto que es esta ceremonia este
ritual siento nuestros ancestros
somos parte de esto también de la
tradición y además
en ese hacer nosotros nos reconocemos y
eso es lo que nos da la conciencia de
nuestra vida en todo en todos nuestros
aspectos de la vida ya se cerró el pozo
se completaron las ofrendas terminó la
ceremonia la ceremonia de la pachamama
en la que se marca el inicio del
despertar y todo el mes de agosto está
dedicado a la pachamama es una ceremonia
que se repetirá otra vez el año que
viene en toda la región andina en los
pueblos de esas zonas pero también en
lugares como este aquí en buenos aires